[Music]
there are two antithetical forms of this
relation one is a relationship to the
state power and wealth as to something
of like nature to itself the other ends
to something disparate from it the
consciousness which finds them of like
nature to itself is Noble it sees in
public authority what is in accord with
itself sees in it its own simple essence
and the factual evidence of it and in
the service of that authority its
attitude towards it is one of actual
obedience and respect similarly in the
case of wealth that see is that this
procures for an awareness of its other
essential side the consciousness of
being for itself if the air for looks
upon wealth likewise as essential in
relation to itself and acknowledges the
source of its enjoyment as a benefactor
to whom it lies under an obligation
in the previous paragraph Hegel had made
a distinction within consciousness
itself in terms of the good and bad no
longer being simply one polarity or the
other with state power and wealth but in
terms of the consciousness itself here
in paragraph 500 he's going to start to
spell this out and he's going to talk
about one of these key terms here the
the Noble or Adel mu tiga right the the
literal nobly minded nobly spirited
consciousness and then afterwards he'll
talk about the base consciousness in the
next paragraph and what he tells us is
that we can see this this split taking
place within consciousness itself
there's an unlike this if we want to
play on the gleich and and unlike you
know the like and here translated by
Miller this disparate right unlike
aspects within consciousness itself but
there's there's two possibilities for
how consciousness comports itself in
relation to state power and in relation
to wealth notice that Hegel doesn't give
us four different possible combinations
here where perhaps consciousness could
be like to stay power but unlike to to
wealth or unlike the state power and
like to wealth instead it's either like
to both of them or unlike to both of
them and why is that the case well
consciousness itself is not identifying
itself with these two powers these two
modes of the ethical substance state
power and wealth it is being itself and
it's being itself in relation to both of
these it's a sort of global comportment
in relation to the social world so how
does Hegel frame this you says there are
two antithetical to opposed forms of
this relation one is a relation of the
two the state power and wealth is
something of like nature something like
to to itself the other is something did
spirit from it so he says the
consciousness which finds them of like
nature is is the noble consciousness
right now what makes it Noble here's
where Hegel gets into some description
he's not going to flesh this out
completely is giving us the outline at
this point we're going to look a few
paragraphs ahead to see it it's spelled
out in great detail what does it see in
state power it finds its own essence as
we've seen already in the state power in
the authority that is vested there it
says it finds its own simple essence and
the evidence of it and what does it
provide then what is the relation to the
state power and it's Authority it says
in the service of that authority its
attitude towards it as one of actual
obedience and respect that is what makes
it a noble consciousness now it's not
you know simply obeisance it doesn't you
know I am not worthy at all or anything
like that it sees the state power as of
like nature to itself so it can
recognize it it's something it sees
itself as good and it can see the state
power is good and that is why it can
render it obedience and respect it might
have to you know extend it a little bit
of license at certain points you know
you look at the king and you're like
yeah I'm not that good of a king but I
guess you know kingship you know the the
authority I I really need to make an
effort here to show some respect or we
could talk about the office of the
presidency or we can talk you know in
very simple terms of the President of
the PTA or
some some other you know low-level
organization like that so long as we're
treating it as something where there is
a legitimate authority this is a
possibility for the noble consciousness
we would use other terms in our own time
we wouldn't talk about in terms of noble
we might say stand-up person or you know
somebody of integrity but that's what
Hegel is after here what about in
relation to wealth so there's also a
finding something of like nature to
itself in in wealth here as well and he
says in the case of wealth it sees that
this wealth procures for it awareness of
its other essential side the this is
also essential this is also visa bleak
right consciousness of being for itself
wealth is what offers in this scheme the
very possibility of being for itself and
so he says it looks upon wealth as
essential in relation to itself and
acknowledges wealth as the source of its
enjoyment as a benefactor to whom it
lies under an obligation so it treats
the wealth and by this we don't just
mean you know having money or currency
or something like that but this whole
economic process it sees that as
providing the human being the noble
consciousness with an understanding of
what it is and with something that it
can enjoy it is wealth or the economic
process is a benefactor and it
recognizes its own role in this you know
it might see itself I don't know as a
job creator or as you know a consumer a
good consumer that is that is promoting
the the benefits to all within the
system so this is the mindset of the
noble consciousness
the consciousness which adopts the other
relation is on the contrary ignoble it
claims to the disparity between the two
essentiality x' the sees and the
sovereign power a fetter and a
suppression of its own being for self
and therefore hates the ruler obeys only
with a secret malice and is always on
the point of revolt
it sees to it wealth by which it attains
to the enjoyment of its own
self-centered existence only the
disparity with its permanent in essence
sense through wealth it becomes
conscious of itself merely as an
isolated individual conscious only of a
transitory enjoyment loving yet hating
wealth and with the passing of the
enjoyment of something that is
essentially evanescent in regards its
relation to the rich as also having
vanished
in paragraph 501 Hegel now begins to
treat what we call the base or ignoble
in German need attracting a
consciousness and we're going to talk
about that that term and what Wyatt is
you know sort of interesting in its
original in just a moment but what we
want to keep in mind is we're looking at
the same sort of schema right we have a
consciousness there's a antithesis
between the noble and the base two
different ways of looking at things and
what constitutes those ways of looking
at things whether it sees in state power
or in wealth which is at the opposite
end of state power something like itself
something unlike itself something as we
have translated like or disparate
something equal to itself or you might
even say adequate to itself or something
in which there's there's a kind of
disharmony a conflict a not fitting
together a incommensurate e we might say
and so the the ignoble consciousness the
base consciousness is going to look at
these these two things in a very
different way it's almost as if it's
seeing a completely different social
world than what the noble consciousness
is seeing so what we're setting up here
is not only a conflict between say state
power and wealth but between these two
different kinds of consciousness and the
way in which they interpret matters
they're in a way in commence herbal with
each other
so what Hegel tells us that it clings to
the the disparity between the two
essentiality z-- now that's an
interesting place to start with the
noble consciousness what we saw is it
could go for state power because that's
like itself it can also go for wealth
because that's like it's often the two
of those could be harmonized in a
certain sense with each other they could
work together what about the the ignoble
consciousness no this is what is aware
of the conflicts the contradict
taking place that's part of what makes
it ignoble it can't be content it can't
find its its place this is going to be
very important from the perspective of
culture as we're going to see as we go
through later paragraphs so he says it
sees in the sovereign power a fetter and
a suppression of its own being for self
if we want to be a little facetious here
the state power is the man that you want
to stick it to but you can't you have to
be quiet and know your place and do your
your job because you don't want to get
punished but you know you would love to
speak up you would love to do things
differently do things you know the way
that you see them as fit but state power
gets in your way the law the government
it's telling you what to do
it's constituting an impediment to
realizing your own desires realizing
what it is that you're meant to be your
being for itself so what is the attitude
then here Hegel talks about malice and
revolt it obeys only with a secret
malice it does obey but secretly inside
it wants to say screw you I'm not doing
what you you want me to do and so this
is the the waiter who spits in your food
this is the person who through you know
sort of willful carelessness screws up
the the thing for the the governmental
office this is the clerk who fills out
forms slightly incorrect and gums up the
work so yeah secret malice and as he
says a kind of revolt right he says it's
always on the point of revolt it's
always ready it may spend its entire
life or a career never actually
revolting but it but it's it's it's
right there if they just
push me one more bit if you've ever seen
the movie office space somebody who I
suppose is kind of like that although it
you know a certain respect here he does
embody certain aspects of the noble
consciousness but then I guess becomes
the base consciousness is Milton with
his stapler you know if they've just
given him his friggin stapler back he
wouldn't have burned the whole place
down right but it many people just
suffer in silence or they say little
things here and there about the state
power you know they see the emblems or
the representatives of it then they
always got to have a little bit of
things to say Oh often perhaps ins in
social media by the way this is similar
to what Nietzsche later on is going to
call the spirit of resentiment
isn't it now what about wealth so Hegel
talks about that here is well he says
it's seize and wealth by which it
attains to the enjoyment of its own
self-centered existence so wealth is
good for something right only the
disparity with its permanent essence
only something that can't really give it
what it wants this we might not only
think of in terms of money can't buy you
happiness or money can't buy you love
but also in terms of that old by this
point old idea of you know 400 channels
and nothing on you can you can have all
these things offered to you but none of
them seem to really satisfy and you you
identify yourself through consumption
through production through exchange but
none of it ever really comes close to
what it is that you truly desire what do
you get instead he talks about
experiencing oneself as an isolated
individual and when we think of the
world in terms of wealth rather than in
terms of the state that is in fact how
we look at things Homo economicus is
indeed a person all by themselves
without any sort of social ties just a
bunch of preffer
that's a form of what Hegel's calling
the ignoble consciousness or the base
consciousness we also have transitory
enjoyment we don't have any truly
satisfying enjoyment that a person can
have once and then be done with no it
all goes away says the this person then
loves and hates wealth and with the
passing of the enjoyment something that
is essentially evanescent it regards its
relation to the rich as also having
vanished so this is something in stable
and in both cases there is a lack of
well you know I brought up this you know
wouldn't you like and like you know
there's an inadequacy an inadequate a
not being entirely what one wants to be
this is neither attracting a is kind of
interesting right
because this is actually a more active
way of talking about things this is the
person who pulls things down
neither below who needs to disparage who
needs to see things in a worse way
that's why I brought up Nietzsche and
resentiment which I think is perfectly
appropriate to see here in terms of the
noble and the base consciousness
now these relations Express in the first
instance the judgment the determination
of what these two essential realities
are as objects for consciousness not as
yet what they are in and for themselves
the reflection which is presented in the
judgment is partly an affirmation of the
one as of the other only for us and is
therefore an equal annulling of both it
is not yet the reflection of them for
consciousness itself partly at first
there simply are as essences they have
not become such nor do they possess
self-consciousness that for which they
are is not that which animates them they
are predicates which are not yet
themselves subject I've come to this
separation the whole of the spiritual
judgment falls apart into two
consciousness each of which is subject
to a one-sided determination now just as
at first the indifference of the two
sides of the alienation one of which was
the in itself of pure consciousness that
is the specific thoughts of good and man
the other their existence as state power
and wealth was raised into a relation
between them into a judgment so must
this external relation be raised to an
inner unity or to a relation of thought
to actuality and the spirit of both
forms of the judgment must make its
appearance this happens where the
judgment becomes a syllogism
that is becomes the mediating process in
which the necessity and the middle term
of both sides of the judgment come to
view
here in paragraph 502 Hegel is now
bringing in some logical considerations
that that have to do specifically with
these notions of the the noble and base
consciousness and what we're supposed to
do with this in relation to state power
and wealth and there's there's a little
bit of reference to what took place in
in the previous paragraphs a couple
paragraphs back that helps us to
understand this but really the key thing
that I think is probably gonna throw a
lot of people is he starts out talking
about a judgement and the need to
transform the judgment into a syllogism
which strikes us usually as well this is
logic right this has to do with at the
very least some sort of argument that's
being made the syllogism is a kind of
argument what is Hegel on about here
he's not actually gonna provide us with
any syllogism at this point so you might
say well where where is it it's
important to keep I suppose two things
in mind one is that the the syllogism
itself and judgments are not just part
of logic but also you know traditionally
what is been often you know substituted
for logic dialectic and Hegel is
carrying out a dialectic that is very
complicated here very different than say
dialectic and Plato or Aristotle and
even different from what we're gonna see
later on and Marx talked about his
dialectic so there's that the other
thing to keep in mind is that when Hegel
brings up the syllogism it's almost it's
almost always gonna be with him making
some reference as he does right here to
mediation to a middle term you know
that's that's what allows you to have a
syllogism in the first place you have a
you know two different terms and somehow
they're going to be connected up
together through a third term through
this this structure of argumentation or
inquiry or reasoning right so that's
that's important now turn into what
Hegel actually
is discussing here he says least these
relations what are what are the
relations likeness unlike miss the noble
consciousness the ignoble consciousness
they express he says the judgment the
determination the Boosh teaming the
giving determinant is to what these two
essential realities these essences these
visas are for are as as objects objects
for what for consciousness so a judgment
is a way for consciousness to make sense
out of in this case of course
what are these essences well and state
power right it turns them into objects
for the the consciousness Annie says the
reflection which is presented in the
judgment is partly an affirmation of the
one as of the other but only for us not
for these things as they are in and for
themselves and then he says something a
little bit striking here he talks about
you know perhaps we might say a
distorting effect that our judgments
have in that we're not grasping wealth
and state power as they really are as
they are he says in and for themselves
they have not gotten to that that point
or rather consciousness has not gotten
to that point he says they don't possess
self-consciousness that for which they
are is not that which animates them what
is that for which they are consciousness
the individual the acting individual the
ethical individual who is trying to
figure out where he or she fits in the
social sphere wealth and state power
confront them as something that he says
are predicates for which are not yet
themselves subjects again logical
terminology right so he says on account
of this separation the whole of the
spiritual judgment falls apart into two
consciousness is the noble and the base
consciousness right and he says each of
which is subject to a one-sided
determination
now that is really interesting and
that's what's partly going to get us to
the
notion of the syllogism and the
mediation both the noble and the base
consciousness are partly right but
they're also partly wrong neither one of
them is getting the whole picture so
Hegel goes on and he says just as at
first the indifference of the two sides
a in a nation one of which was the in
itself the specific thoughts are good
and bad the other their existence the
state program well this is what I was
talking about we looked at this several
paragraphs ago was raised into a
relation between them into a judgment we
must raise this external relation to an
inner unity to a relation of thought to
actuality and the spirit of both forms
of the judgment must make its appearance
right the the mind the unifying
perspective so what we're talking about
here is developing a more adequate
perspective than the partly adequate
perspectives of the noble and based
consciousness how are we going to do
this Hegel talks about here
we need a syllogism the judgment turns
into a syllogism what does that mean he
says it becomes the mediating process
right so we have a process of
consciousness we have a process of
development here and he says in which
the necessity and the middle term of
both sides of the judgment come to view
so you know we're not we're not talking
about a syllogism in the way that we
normally think about it you know
Socrates is mortal all men are mortal
therefore Socrates is more we're not
talking about that sort of thing we're
talking about a process by which we show
some sort of necessity we actually sort
of unfold it or we we find it or build
it within the partial perspectives that
means we have to engage in what Hegel is
calling off a bone and we're gonna see
that happen in the paragraphs yet to
come